membre de gang de rue.
La police de l'a pas cru.
On a demandé à notre panel de
revenir sur cela.
Bonsoir.
Mme Plante avait un choix devant
elle souhaite garder Monsieur
Prosper soit qu'ils aient tous
les matins je crois qu'elle
était à Arcan, c'est terminé, il
n'est plus mon candidat. Il a
décidé de les garder. Expliciter
la bonne ou la mauvaise
décision?
- Ça va coûter cher et je pense
qu'elle est susceptible de
revenir sur cette décision dans
les prochaines semaines. On le
sait maintenant, il n'y a plus
de tolérance pour la moindre
erreur. M. Coderre va se régaler
de cela.
Il faut le dire aussi que comme
mère de Montréal-Nord dans un
contexte où il va devoir
travailler avec les policiers,
il va devoir nous expliquer
comment la confiance avec les
policiers il va devoir la
rétablir.
Dans le fond, Sega a des grandes
talents. Il a Montréal Nord
tatoué sur le coeur. Il doit ne
nous convaincre qu'il va avoir
la confiance de la police.
- Donc vous dites : elle aurait
dû s'en départir malgré les bons
coups qu'elle a eus.
- Je l'ai dit pour des raisons
politiques elle va s'en départir
ou elle aurait dû s'en départir
ça lui aurait fait gagner des
boîtes. Maintenant, pour changer
Montréal-Nord peut-être que ça
mère personne.
- Qu'est-ce que Rady par la
mairesse?
- Écoutez, moi je suis partagé.
J'ai connu Monsieur Prosper.
Il a fait du bien.
Cependant, actuellement, ces
c'est qu'effectivement on ne
peut pas qualifier ça d'erreur
de jeunesse. Il avait 27 ans il
était responsable de ses actes.
Il a fait pour contacter ses
amis proches qui étaient dans
les gang de rue supposément
comme vous l'aviez dit dans une
enquête.
C'est quand même assez troublant
parce que demain matin Prosper
est élu maire, on sait qu'avec
tous les problèmes, quelle va
être son autorité à discuter
avec le poste police de
quartier?
Pour l'instant, les policiers
n'ont aucune confiance. Il
répète infirmier il aurait pu
être médecin il repaître
Docteur, il aurait pu être
toutes sortes de choses et
aujourd'hui on ne serait pas là
pour en parler parce que cela
n'aurait pas d'influence sur sa
capacité de prendre des
décisions.
- C'est un point intéressant que
vous soulevez.
En même temps, même si on est
convaincu qu'il fera, s'il est
élu un bon travail est-ce la
faute même si ces il y a 22 ans
n'est pas telle que aujourd'hui
dans le contexte de sécurité et
où il y a un peu d'angoisse à
Montréal la mairesse n'aurait
pas le choix de lui dire au
revoir?
- En fait, il a menti à son
institution. Il a menti à son
parti.
On est forcé de révéler tout ce
qui pourrait nuire à l'image du
parti. Vraisemblablement, il ne
l'a pas fait.
Nous n'avons pas été élevés à
Montréal-Nord ni Madame Sanson
et moi, nous n'avons pas connu
de criminels et nous n'avons pas
côtoyé la pauvreté et la
marginalité. Lui, il a quand
même tout ça. C'est son bagage.
Se débarrasser de ce bagage...
c'est très très rare qu'on se
présente comme mère avec ce
bagage.
Il voulait donner des millions
de dollars pour le
communautaire.
- Il peut faire du bien et en
même temps quand tu es mairesse
est-ce que tu peux passer
l'éponge sur une affaire comme
ça?
- Sa clientèle n'est pas celle
de l'autre équipe sa clientèle
sa clientèle de jeunes en marge
de la société.
Il est allé la chercher. La
grande surprise qui pourra y
avoir, c'est de lui faire de la
publicité parce que ces jeunes
qui n'ont peut-être jamais été
votés vont peut-être se
mobiliser davantage pour dire
nous on a une chance de faire
élire cet homme et on va aller
voter. Ça ne fait pas partie de
notre 42 % de taux de
participation. C'est peut-être
l'élément de dire on a la chance
de faire élire quelqu'un comme
nous.
- Mobiliser.
30 secondes chacun. Je vous
repose la question mais plus
clairement. Vous êtes maire vous
êtes mairesse vous auriez fait
quoi ce matin?
- Moi, je leur ai gardé mais il
faut dire que je ne suis pas élu
et je ne suis pas électible.
- Malgré le coût politique.
- Je vous dirai que content tenu
des circonstances et malgré les
qualités qu'il peut avoir dans
Montréal-Nord, actuellement avec
la situation des gangs de rue,
la confiance n'aurait pas été là
parce que avec nos policiers ont
n'aurait pas pu régler le
problème.
- Même si je t'aime, va-t'en.